ينورنا من عمان مراسل العربيه عمار الهندي
يسعد صباحك يا عمار يعطيك الف عافيه اهلا
بك منورنا اليوم
تسلمي صباح الخير لك ولدين ولكل المشاهدين
عمار كم احتاج من الوقت كي انسى ما شاهدته
هنا يعني كان هذا التعليق على منشور لك
على مواقع التواصل حدثنا لماذا كتبت هذا
ومشاهداتك العينيه في زلزال تركيا
لا هو عموما الصحافه اللي بغطي حروب او
ازمات او كوارث وانا هذه هذا الشيء عشته
بعد تغطيه معركه كييف يدخل في مرحله
كوابيس اولا يعني خلال في المنام يبدا
بمرحله كوابيس في حرب بعد التغطيه بدات
معي بعد اسبوع تقريبا بس ابشركم موضوع
الزلزال بدا اليوم يعني انا اليوم استفقت
على كابوس له علاقه بالزلزال وهذا بحد
ذاته متوقع بالنسبه لي لانه
اعلم انه عقلي الباطن فيك كثير من المشاهد
في كثير من الالام في كثير من يعني صراحه
حسره وغضب واحيان كثيره عجز لانه بالفعل
هذه التغطيه هذه الكارثه كانت اصعب بكثير
من من حرب اوكرانيا من تغطيه الحرب رغم
انه في اوكرانيا فكيف شاهدنا مئات الجثث
ورؤوس مقطعه وغيره ومشاهد مؤلمه ولكن هذه
المره الموضوع مختلف لانه لما تفكر فيه هو
ما الذي حدث الذي حدث انه ملايين الناس
الساعه اربعه وثلث تقريبا فجرا الناس نيام
ساعات نوم
ضرب مناطق واسعه زلزال مدمر كل الناس هذه
اللي كانت في منازلها اصبحت تحت الركب
هذا هذا هذه الفكره بحد ذاتها صادمه اسمعك
عمار عاده عاده لما يشوف الانسان مصايب
غيره بيحمد ربه وبصير يقدر ابسط الامور
اللي عنده شو اللي تغير فيك عمار الانسان
بعد تجربه تغطيه الزلزال
في الحقيقه كل شيء يعني كل شيء انا اليوم
الحمد لله في عمان عدت امس
انا ماشي بسيارتي وانا بالشارع وانا بشوف
الناس تتحرك بشكل طبيعي هذا هذا الشيء
فعلا فعلا اختلف كثيرا يعني حتى من لما
انتقلنا منها تاي الى اسطنبول وشفت الحياه
طبيعيه انا فعليا كنت في صدمه لانه تقريبا
عشر ايام او 11 يوم انت تسير في طرقات
مدمره بالكامل كلها جثث كلها رائحه موت
والمناسبه التحدي الصحافي كان كبير جدا
لانه انت تحتاج ان تكون دقيق وتراعي مشاعر
الناس يعني رغم ان رائحه الموت كانت في كل
مكان لكن يصعب عليك ان تستخدم مثلا كلمه
رائحه كريهه يصعب عليك حتى لا تجرح احد
يعني انت كنت الصحافي يكون محاصر بالفعل
بانه يكون مهني يكون ملتزم بخط المهني
عاطفيا ما بقدر ولكن في كثير من الاحيان
يعني كنا كنت اكون على الهواء ومعي ضيوف
وحالتهم يعني الحاله التي يتحدث فيها
مؤلمه للغايه فعلا كنت اتعمد انه انا اكون
عكس الكاميرا لاني اشعر في لحظه انه قد
فعلا ابكي يعني قد افقد اعصابي
اكثر من لحظه وانت تغطي ميدانيا على
المباشر كانوا يطلبوا منكم السكوت والصمت
عشان يسمعوا اصوات تحت الانقاذ ذي ينقذوها
كيف كان شعورك في هذه اللحظات
سهام هذا الموضوع لو تعطيني شويه دقيقه
اشرح لك هذا اكثر شيء بالنسبه الي مؤلم
يعني لو انا عدت الى عمان ما اكثر شيء
يدور في ذهني اكثر شيء يدور في ذهني انه
في شخص يكون تحت الانقاض ينادي ويصرخ
ويستنجد ولا يسمع احد يعني تخيلي انسان
لما بيكون في بيت مثلا واغلق عليه باب
بيته ما معاه تليفون وما حدا سامعه الشعور
ممكن ينجن اذا قعد ايام ما حدا سامعه ومش
عارف يطلع من بيته مثلا محاصر في بيته ما
بالك بشخص تحت انقاض وركام بدون ماء بدون
كهرباء في برد قارس وشديد كنت كل شخص
اشوفه والتقي فيه من الناجين اسالوا هذا
السؤال اقول له بماذا شعرت
يعني احدى النساء قالت لي انت ميت حي انت
في القبر لكنك حي ولا يسمعك احد كثير من
الاحيان كانوا يطلبوا منا الصمت لانه يكون
في مؤشر على حياه انسان ولكن للاسف الشديد
في بعض الحالات
الحديد عنيد يعني كان اعند من اي اله يعني
حينما تستغرق عمليه الانقاذ لهذا الشخص
الحي ومتاكدين انه حي تستغرق مثلا اربع
ساعات او خمس ساعات عمار لانه
يكون فارق الحياه للاسف يعني في دائما في
نقطه مهمه كمان
الكارثه طالت الجميع لم تفرق بين جنسيه او
قوميه لكن هل لاحظتم نوعا من العنصريه في
التعاطي مع المنكوبين هل كانت حالات فرديه
ام حاله عامه
الحالات كانت فرديه لا استطيع ان اقول انه
توجه للدوله التركيه مثلا او فرق الانقاذ
كانت حالات فرديه ولكن نعم انا شهدت على
شكاوى كثيره لاشخاص سوريين يعني كانت
مؤلمه بانه يستنجد ولا يجيب احد رايت جثث
على الارض لاشخاص سوريين ومر فريق انقاذ
ورفض انه ينقلهم بعد مرور 24 ساعه وكان من
يجب ان تنقل هذه الجثث وتصور وتدفن رايت
شاب استنجد بنا ونحن على الهواء بانه
نساعده لانه في ثلاث اخوان له تحت الانقاب
تحت تسويه ورفض رفضت فرق الانقاذ
بمساعدتهم ولكن يعني نحن رحنا وطلبنا منهم
وفعلا حفروا بايديهم يعني هم ثلاث اخوان
يبحثوا عن ثلاثه اخرين وللاسف حفروا
وحفروا بايديهم للاسف الشديد
بك يا عمار يعطيك الف عافيه عمر الهندي من
عمان شكرا